i want to i want to show you what defeat
looks like because it's going to put a
shock to the system of the average
person
this is the clip that you should uh
share with your friends and family
the new york times did a profile on
a a controversial educator justine fonte
suddenly being pilloried by parents a
private school sex educator defends her
methods
what was she doing she was showing adult
films to teenagers in high school
to critically analyze gender and showing
a video to six-year-olds
on the nature of screw it masturbation
this is this is what defeat looks like
when the new york times
sends a photographer out to take this
photo look up at the sky
look at this photo they took her
superman why was she being pilloried by
parents
the story basically says that because of
zoom because the classrooms are now
being exposed the parents
saw what she was teaching their children
and they were shocked and angered
and so they reached a journalist saying
what is going on in our schools
she was forced to resign before zoom
in the lockdowns she was doing this for
years and other schools say
it's totally normal and there's nothing
wrong with her curriculum
the new york times sent a photographer
out to do a profile piece on her
where they defend everything she did
teaching six-year-olds
about self-gratification
right defeat talk about your kids
where there's there's this video of a
choir uh uh
singing we're going to convert your
children have you seen it i saw that
mm-hmm
i mean at first i thought they were just
being sarcastic like they were like haha
conservatives we're gonna scare you
but no like you actually listen to the
lyrics i was like wow
it's straight serious we're going to
convert your kids
so that you are forced to support us to
support them
and i'm like you will become an ally it
was crazy crazy
well yeah like once we have your kids
you will be forced to be an ally
what are they talking about converting
them to what to this this weird uh
this weird ideology is this literally
like it's like uh
we wanna dirty your kids your child
comes home
and says i hate you i hate you i hate
you
and you don't understand why i saw this
really sad story it was a post i read it
from a guy who said
i sent my daughter to college and she
was a normal high school girl when she
came back her head was shaving on the
sides
dyed different colors she had weird
makeup on and she told me i was evil and
disgusting and she hated me and i don't
understand what happened right that's
the problem
people think china is the bad guy
it's like that's the thing could that be
china you know um i think
china in many ways is just uh
unfortunately i don't say this as
admiring china i
say it as shame on us because we need to
do better
but again it's recognizing reality
is china does not subscribe to this
nonsense
china in this respect is a very serious
country and i could absolutely see
americans in the very near future if not
now
who want their children to have a
serious education
send them to the best universities in
china that won't give them the work [ __ ]
because you know what if china is smart
the professors at their best
universities are going to be
the people who would normally be the
best professors in america
what who would get cancelled by american
academia the people who want to study
and say the things
that you can't study and say in american
academia
china i think they should set up
tenured chairs at least five per
major university and invite the most
controversial but serious american
scholars
give them chairs there and it's again
this is
a win-win this is a win for them in
terms of pr
and it's a win for the serious american
scholars who want to be able to study
without getting canceled in a serious
environment
who gets banned on social media it is
typically conservatives you say
something like learn to code
you're gone antifa can literally
organize and tell people where to go to
engage in violence
and they're totally safe i mean i love
it when i was on when i was on joe rogan
with dorsey and vijaya
uh when i was like here's a literal
tweet inciting violence
that you clearly have seen because tons
of responses were removed but you didn't
respond you didn't
remove this one and they're like oh
about that and they and i think they
only did it after the show i
was like i'm not going to tell you they
wanted me to give them the er i wasn't
going to do it but that's that's who get
banned
they told me we have to protect people
who are at risk of suicide that's why
they have specific rules protecting the
trans community
what is china banning you see the story
about what china's banning
china is banning the lgbtq community
there you go
from the guardian outrage over shutdown
of lgbtq wechat accounts in china
dozens of wechat accounts have been
blocked and deleted without warning
right china knows the risks of
of of destroying the family no they know
the risks of destroying the family
and they know the risks of the globalist
american empire poison
that's why i say thank god that they've
banned google
and they have not subjected themselves
to the so-called open society
the open society means allowing western
ngos in their country
allowing western tech infrastructure to
control
the dissemination of information they've
refused those things
and for that reason and that reason
alone they are
a genuinely sovereign country my
position is really there are two and a
half
genuinely sovereign countries on this
planet there's united states globalist
american empire
there's china and russia gets a half
because it's more complicated
there are only two and a half genuinely
sovereign countries
and the reason china is up there is
because it completely bans
western big tech infrastructure
and bans western ngos they know it
george soros was trying to get it
insinuate himself into china as far back
as the 70s
they refused it that if it is
the second they stop doing that is the
second that
china uh becomes effectively a part of
the globalist american empire but but
but china
sucks china is authoritarian they're
awful
right they're their militant ethnic
state
yeah right and you know they're they're
awful they're off on a different way
and they're awful in a way that simply
does not embrace
the woke poison i say that and we're
we're kind of awful too
and we're authoritarian too but they are
just not
they can be kind of maybe uh
robotic and automated in some ways there
is this sort of
geopolitical autism that they exhibit
there's a lot that's unattractive about
them and in fact
you know they have everything going for
them but the fact that nobody is
attracted to them as
as a country and that is ultimately a
problem if you want to
have global supremacy there's simply
nothing attractive
they don't have anything resembling the
kind of soft power
that america dominates in or and even
russia to some extent has there's just
no cool factor
no attractive factor that is an extreme
limiting force
i don't think that is an insuperable
problem i think
eventually they'll realize that and
they'll just hire people
probably from the west to um to correct
that
but um but yeah they they suck they're
authoritarian
they're uninspiring but they do not have
drag queen story hour they don't have
drag queen story
concentration camps well for for uyghurs
yeah and um and falun gong
shutting down of you know apple apple
was it apple daily and
what they're doing to hong kong right
and but then that's another thing that i
think is ridiculous is that
we're simply in no position to criticize
that
and they themselves have said this i
think with absolute justification
how can we like we have a just uh a
phalanx of midwit conservative
politicians again
who love pointing their finger at china
i think china is bad they're
authoritarian it's good to point a
finger at them
if you have it in the appropriate
context
but pointing fingers at china and
ignoring the fact
that a sitting president of the united
states was de-platformed from our own
communications infrastructure
and point to china's uh censoring apple
daily and saying they're the
authoritarians
but still bad is complex neither of it's
good
neither of it's good but we don't have
the moral authority to criticize them
it's just two different types of
authoritarianism well the us government
doesn't but we do
sure as long as you're as long as you're
pointing out both and i think
what matters is the context because i
think in the political discourse
especially amongst
politicians conservative politicians
it's so much
easier to point your finger at china one
of uh a tweet i had a while back there
was marsha blackburn who said
oh i'm gonna score points i'm gonna show
how tough i am against those chaicoms
here is uh winnie the pooh guess what
in america we can tweet winnie the pooh
whereas in china you can't because it's
considered critical of xi
i said oh that's great marcia now do
george floyd
right crickets it's to say it's it's the
same point it's not that china is a free
country
it's authoritarian but in in spirit it's
a more serious version of
authoritarianism
it's not this weird grotesque uh
drag queen authoritarianism that we've
seen
in the united states and so they're both
authoritarian and this gets to this
point of taboo arbitrage i pointed out
is that
thank god there's not a singular
authoritarian system
i like the fact that there are things
that you can say in china
and you can get away with saying that
would get you absolutely destroyed in
the united states
and i like that chinese people can come
to united states
and criticize their government i think
the fact that
these different authoritarian systems
have different taboos
is something that can and should be
arbitraged and that might be one of the
few silver linings going forward
to carve out a space of genuinely free
and open discourse man yeah i think
about like if i was president tomorrow
and i really wanted to
up in the deep state like repeal the cia
like do what kennedy wanted to do
basically
you'd have to go to russia to be safe if
you were in the united states right they
just they know where you live no i mean
that's the thing
assange's mistake is he didn't go to
russia snowden did and that's why
snowden is where he is and why
assange is when he is and it's like not
that's
an extension of what i was saying that
there's only two and a half real
sovereign
countries on this planet yeah what about
india
um i think to some extent but they don't
have
that deep autonomy in the sense that
china does
what are they missing exactly because
they have nukes they have a huge
population
what is what are they missing is it
infrastructure they're not the farmland
or something
um well i think they're i think it gets
to this
open society idea they they're they're
um far more integrated into the west in
that
sort of basic um information
infrastructure
sense they don't ban google
and therefore um uh the
the us uh basically has information
dominance from that point of view
so maybe because it was a british colony
for so long
they've established like the secret
infrastructure was already ready to go
by the time now that they're independent
yeah i mean certainly there's a
different history too that
that impacts that but it's not to say
like
i'm i'm basically stipulating gradations
of sovereignty in in as technical
geopolitical sense yes they're sovereign
but i'm saying ultimately what does
sovereign mean
sovereign if you're a sovereign country
you should be able to house
edward snowden and i don't think india
could do that
regardless of uh if china is sovereign i
mean
as bad as the us is it's much better
than china
i mean we've got we've got issues here
that we're trying to work out we've got
internal conflict the culture war and
the domination by this
new cult of this fringe
moral-less framework but
china was welding people's doors shut
during the outbreak they were
instructing their citizens to buy up ppe
from other countries to siphon it away
while they were lying to the wall to the
world health organization
they're uh you know weaker muslims the
conflict with pakistan
hong kong taiwan i mean it's it's it's
brutal and it's awful
yeah there's a lot of bad things i think
there are a lot of bad things with
us being an american i'm far more
concerned
with our problems and again i think it
all of these things have to be
understood contextually every country
has problems china's an authoritarian
system
i think a lot of these things are can be
uh exaggerated through our media to
feed into this cold war 2.0 and also
simply to distract because they want
people pointing to china pointing to the
thai comms
and they don't want people pointing
fingers at the people who actually run
our country
and i think it you know i'm
a huge fan of you know it's it's great
that the truth about
well um
yeah forget that sorry welcome to
youtube
welcome to america you know aren't we
glad we aren't in china where you can't
just talk about things freely that's
right
literally welcome to america home land
of the free home of the bridge
of the alphabet yeah in china you can't
criticize xi jinping on youtube here's a
big
list of everything you can't say hey
here's a photo of tiananmen
square everybody was sharing those on
twitter and laughing about it
and there are things you cannot say on
youtube because they will just
delete you exactly because big tech big
tech is an extension of our national
security apparatus which is an
authoritarian
regime right very similar in many ways
china is smart not to allow american
tech infrastructure
i think they would be smart to say look
we're not doing business with any
american tech companies that censor
their own citizens i
is would you say that the the
american security organization apparatus
is
is like a subsidiary of big tech or that
big tech is a subsidiary of that and is
it only because of who has the guns
right now
um it's i mean these things
can become complicated over time because
ultimately
institutions institutions can
kind of become self-operating
but also their people and you see
a revolving door effect within google
you see
the phenomenon of people like jared
cohen
the founder of jigsaw he was a key
figure
in hillary clinton state department
in george bush's state department he set
up jigsaw within google which is this
powerful think tank within google
and basically they're tasked with
developing
ai capabilities to censor speech
and he i think personifies this example
of this revolving door between the state
department and big tech to the point
that
is one the subsidiary of another i think
ultimately
it it's more accurate to say that big
tech is the subsidiary of the national
security state
but it's actually an extension of it's
an extension of in the way
that say you have all of these intel
cutouts who aren't formally part of the
intelligence community but do their work
and you see that in these
ngos and organizations that combat
so-called disinformation
that's a huge word you hear and you have
you know
what one of the the few booming sectors
of our economy now is like
quote unquote disinformation journalists
and you have them working for these ngos
like the atlantic council that's joined
at the hip with
you know all of these like government
associated uh organizations it used to
be that the government would just do
this kind of stuff like project
mockingbird and stuff like this
um but now they use these cutouts these
ngos like the atlantic council and there
are a million of them like that
and they employ these journalists who
attack disinformation
which is a term of art it's an
intelligence term and they basically use
that to
um envelop any narratives that counter
regime agenda they envelop those
narratives
into a national security context saying
these are disinformation
and that invites this national security
imprimatur once it becomes a national
security issue that means it's
no longer an issue for discussion it's
no longer a normal political debate
within
a deliberative democratic arena it
becomes this is natural security
therefore shut up
and that's the work that this vocabulary
like disinformation is doing
and this is being done chiefly through
intel cutouts not
formally part of the government and i
think you need to understand
the big tech companies as much more
robust
um versions of this this ecology
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time